Hello, hello, sorry.
I'm all over the place.
Tomorrow, you'll find out.
That's all I can say.
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow is the announcement.
And you know what?
I am more all over the place than usual.
I'm very stressed out.
Tomorrow at 12 p.m.
on Twitter, you will find out why I am a mess and I had to delay the stream a little bit.
Because I got a last minute work message that I had to like answer.
And then I had... there were so many other...
So yes, sorry for those who don't have Twitter, but that's where the announcement's gonna be.
Unfortunately, for those non-Twitter users.
I will make a community post about it later.
But obviously, it won't be at the same time.
It will be a few hours later after the Twitter announcement.
I will be very busy tomorrow.
So, unfortunately, I can't be streaming tomorrow to be like, Hey, bro, talk about it.
But tomorrow is the announcement.
It'll be at 12 p.m.
and you'll find out on Twitter.
Yes, anyway.
But what was that?
What else?
What was that?
Oh, yeah.
I talked about those who are in member stream.
They get exclusive like first news.
They get exclusive first dad news because I streamed members first.
So, dad update.
It was, like usual, being the dog that he is.
12 p.m.
PST, by the way.
PST, the my time zone.
The correct time zone.
So, dad update.
So, last night, yesterday, when I was doing his little walkies at the dog park, he saw another pretty lady.
I know we just had a pretty lady short that just came out today.
Anyway, so this was another pretty lady at the park.
Um, and she had a little, another poodle terrier, as always.
I have no idea why it's always poodle terriers.
I, I personally think that I am not a fan of these little poodle terriers.
You know, they come in all different colors.
Brown, mostly brown.
Um, those like curly poodle terriers because they're like, they don't shed or anything.
But I don't find them very cute, in my opinion.
I'm sorry if you own one.
I just see them so much that I've been like desensitized by poodle terriers because I just see them so much.
Like, even when I lived, it's a very popular breed in China as well.
I remember because like a lot of my friends own poodle terriers as well.
And I've seen them so much.
And, uh, they're very light though.
I remember like, not chucking one of my friend's dogs.
Or when I, like, compared to like, because I also had a wiener dog back then.
Um, but like, compared to like, weight between a poodle terrier and, um, and like wiener dogs.
Wiener dogs are so much heavier than poodle terriers.
It's actually crazy.
Um, I'm just like, where, where, where is all your meat?
Like, they're so, poodle terriers are so skinny.
They're like, incredibly skinny.
Like, underneath their fur.
But like, um, wiener dogs, dachshunds, they're like, fucking built.
You know?
Like, dachshunds are like, muscle.
And...
Or not.
They're either muscles or chonky as fuck.
Um...
Like, I remember, um...
I don't understand how dad, how food motivated he is.
Is like, just muscle.
Like, I remember when I would walk dad.
And then like, people would be like, wow, he's so muscular.
Like, look at those legs.
Look at those arms.
I don't understand.
It's, it's either like, they're like, muscular.
Or they're like, fat as fuck.
Cause it's so easy.
Apparently, it's very easy to make a fat weenie.
Like...
Yeah, he has to stay fit for the ladies.
Ladies!
Um...
Yeah.
But like, anyway.
Um, there's no in-between.
There isn't.
There actually isn't.
Cause like, uh...
Don't say it like that.
Um...
Anyway.
As I was saying.
He, uh...
You know.
The poodle terrier thought that dad was here for...
For him.
For the other dog.
Cause you know.
He's like, oh!
Friends!
You know?
Like...
The poodle terrier is like, yippee!
Friend!
And then...
So...
Because he was in front of his...
Her owner.
Like his or her owner.
I don't know what gender.
Like...
Like the poodle terrier was in front of the owner.
And then obviously dad was like...
Was just walking straight towards the owner.
But the poodle terrier thought that he was walking straight towards him.
And then, obviously, he just walked past the poodle terrier.
Straight to the pretty lady.
And was...
And just sat down and looked at her.
Like, pet me.
You know, you wanna pet me.
And then obviously...
The other dog was so fucking confused.
Cause he was like...
What?
He was...
He was so confused, because he was like, he was really hyped up to like, you know, play with dad.
And he's like, what?
And then he like walked back over to them, walked over to the dad and the pretty lady, you know, his owner.
And then was like trying to get dad's attention and was like sniffing him and was like, hey, you know, I exist too.
And and then dad just kept ignoring the other dog.
And then like, you know, the terror, the terror, putteria was just like, no, don't ignore me.
Come on, let's play.
And then dad looked at and then dad looked at the dog.
He looked at it like that.
And then he like was like.
Like.
And then looked at the owner.
He's like, shush, the adults are talking right now.
It's like, shush, gone.
The adults are trying to talk, little man.
And I'm just like, Jesus, I'm just like, I'm like, Jesus, I'm sorry.
He's so, also, I think he's poop shy.
I think, I think he's poop shy when there's too many dogs, he refuses to poop.
And it's like, so frustrating.
Because I'm like, oh my, when there's nobody there, or like, he's just too distracted with the pretty ladies.
It's either he's poop shy or he's too distracted with the pretty ladies around whenever there's like other owners.
Anyway, but yes, that is the dad update for today.
Okay, alright, so.
I don't know if I'm gonna try it one shot the Onimusha.
So, because I did, you know, how long to complete this game.
And they said it's like, you know, five to eight hours depending on, depending on how fucked I am.
Um, so, and how difficult this game is.
So, I'm not sure.
So, we'll see how it goes.
We'll see how, how, uh, apparently it's this, they said this game is pretty short.
So, it's five to eight hours.
So, I guess it like takes, I don't know, but I'm very excited to play Onimusha.
I used to call it Onimushu because it sounds better.
I don't know, it just rolls off the tongue a lot better, you know, Onimushu versus Onimusha.
And, um, for those who are like, oh, you should have played Onimusha, uh, one.
I did.
You might have to look around for the archive of that.
You might have to.
But, like, I, I was very excited to find out that Onimusha 2 is finally coming up.
Because I actually, uh, grew up watching my dad play the Onimusha series.
And, um, and it was a game that I've always wanted to play myself.
And I always had nightmares of that one skeleton monster in Onimusha.
You know, the one, the one skeleton, you know, the one skeleton demon.
I used to have nightmares of that guy growing up.
Because I would watch my dad play this game at night.
Every day until he finished that game.
Um, but, um, it was, it always seemed like, I always wanted to play, uh, I always wanted to play this game, uh, for the longest time.
No, it was, like, the, the samurai, the samurai, what was this?
The samurai skeleton demons.
Uh, not the scientist skeleton dude.
It was, like, it was, like, they're, like, little demons, little skeleton demons.
And I had, like, nightmares about them.
Um, uh, yeah.
So, like, I remember them very, very vividly.
Uh, just like how I remember the monster in Resident Evil, um, that breaks through the window or some shit.
And, like, um, it's, like, a giant, like, uh, tank guy.
I don't remember which Resident Evil it was.
Um, but there was this, there, I remember, like, with the little ventilator thing.
Um, no, it's, no, not Mr. X.
He has, like, a little ventilator or whatever.
I don't fucking remember.
Um, was Nemesis.
Yes, I think it was, I have trauma with that.
Because my dad would, um, also make me watch him play Resident Evil, uh, growing up as well, like, in his bedroom.
Um, and I would watch him play Resident Evil as well, at nighttime.
And I also had nightmares about it.
So, I had a great childhood growing up.
Uh...
And, I had a great childhood.
Good.
And I would watch that at night while he plays the game at night.
But anyway, I do have more fond memories of Onimusha than I do of Resident Evil.
Because I actually really... I don't know, for some reason, that game was just very interesting to me.
As a little Doki, when I would watch my dad play the game.
So I'm really happy that they did a remaster of the first two games.
Especially the first... because it was a game that I wanted to play myself.
By myself as well.
Because it seemed like a really, really fun game.
And I'm so excited to try it out.
I'm so excited to play Onimusha 2.
I think... I like...
I remember liking Onimusha 1 more than 2.
Just because the designs for me were much more memorable.
I just remember the designs and the environment was much more memorable to me versus 2.
I don't remember much of 2.
I just remember the guy has short hair now.
That's all I remember from the second game.
It's like...
The guy has shorter hair.
Yeah.
So...
So we'll see how it goes.
Alright.
Let's...
Booting up the game for the first time.
Because I should really start testing out games before the stream starts.
That seems a lot smarter to do.
I don't know.
Is he like the son of the first one?
Testing games.
LOL.
Is he the son of the first...
Only...
The first guy?
I already forgot his name.
It's been so long.
Nope.
Different guy.
Unrelated.
They're unrelated?
Oh.
Contents of this game are presented with minimal changes.
Okay.
Powerbive.
Game supports.
Yay!
I love autosave.
Alright.
Let me make sure.
You can review.
I totally read the private policy.
Alright.
Ooh.
That's loud.
Alright.
Let me fix the...
Okay.
Subtitles on...
Vibration.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
We'll do vibration.
Screen...
Screen adjust.
Okay.
No.
I need to do full screen.
Where the fuck is full screen?
PC settings.
Output.
Resolution.
Okay.
There you go.
Full screen.
There we go.
Uh...
Play on controller.
No.
There is sound.
It's just really quiet.
I'll boost up the sound right now.
Um...
I'm stupid because I forgot to use the bathroom before I...
I started.
I had to do work messages.
Sorry.
Alright.
Let me go use the bathroom real quick.
I forgot to use the bathroom before the stream.
Because I was at work.
Literally after the member stream, I had to do work stuff right away.
I'll be back real quick, guys.
Professional streamer.
I'm doing this for how long now?
Still doesn't test games out before you stream.
Uh...
And also forgot to use the bathroom.
Solid Snake, Medi, Floor, Mac, and Alan, Butter, and NS.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oops.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, special features.
Oh, what's this?
Difficulty.
Oh.
Alright.
Let me see what the special features are.
Normal.
Special.
Oh, man.
I'm going to put them on normal because I forgot what they look like.
Alright.
New game.
Mike.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Exactly.
Why do...
Why test it beforehand when I couldn't have chat experience my ad-gross situation?
I'll boost up the volume a little bit for us.
Soon after his victory, Nobunaga fell...
I did that.
However, Nobunaga was far from finished.
I did all that.
Of the demons, he rose from the dead.
Oh, no.
It's the mosquito lady.
Still pretty quiet.
Okay.
That was me!
Yeah,
how many times did we teach this old man a lesson?
Three more times.
Wait.
Two more times.
Because there's two more games.
I wish they do, like...
I wish this game had...
I wish they had more of this game.
Oh.
I need more samurai and demons.
I want an Inuyasha game.
You know...
That's...
I...
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Remember that...
There was...
It was a PlayStation Inuyasha game?
That game was so fun.
I remember playing...
I honestly...
If any game we should...
Uh...
Remasked...
If any game we should bring back...
We should bring back an Inuyasha game.
Oh, I used to play that Inuyasha PS2 game all the way to the end.
The one where it goes through the story?
No, no.
Not the fighter one.
The one that goes through the actual story.
Maybe an Inuyasha character?
Inuyasha?
I know there's also like...
What's...
Sishomaru?
You know which one's not my favorite character.
Your honor...
It's like...
This was basically pre-Edward...
Pre-Edward...
Uh...
What's his name?
Oh my god.
What was the...
What?
Jacob.
It was pre-Edward Jacob.
Before Edward and Jacob.
It's either Inuyasha versus...
Shoshomaru.
The OG Edward and Jacob debate.
Jesus.
Yeah, those are all demons.
Oh no.
No!
Japanese vampire!
How could you do this?
Just another Monday on Feudal Japan.
How could you just let this happen?
Oh no!
I was too busy talking about Inuyasha!
I...
I had my priorities straight!
Oh, that's fucked up.
Wait, he killed that snake for no reason.
I wish they would do like an Inuyasha game.
Donnie, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
A gift for you on my birthday!
Happy birthday, Donnie!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Donnie!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
No, that's not us.
Where the... where the guy with short hair... I actually don't remember these characters.
Like I said, I remembered one more than two.
No, we need an Inuyasha RPG... not an RPG, like, um...
What is it called?
Action RPG?
Like, where it's not RPG... not really fully RPG, but it's more like exploration.
Oh my god, I like this guy.
He has a gun.
Yeah, action adventure.
That could make so much money.
I've always enjoyed the story of Inuyasha.
You know, they made... they tried to make a sequel for... for... Inuyasha to talk about, like, their kids and stuff?
I heard it did really, really bad.
Cause, like, everyone was so hyped about it, and then there was nothing.
And then I heard nothing about it after that.
Like, I was like, wait, what happened to that show?
And I looked it up, and I was like, wait, it's done already?
I was like, yeah, I was like, yeah, I was like, wait, the show is done?
I...
A new warrior, Jubei Yagyu, heard about a demon attack on his hometown, Yagyu Village.
Huh?
Feeling the ominous presentiment in his heart, he desperately raced back home.
What?
Jubei, they're okay, right?
You think they're okay?
They're just sleeping, right?
Guys, don't worry, they're just sleeping.
Wake up!
Why are you sleeping?
Come on, don't be lazy.
Get up, it's work time.
Doesn't have a name?
Like, it's like, name, I know you and you.
And the third guy's like, hey.
Oh, my classic voice, 2000 voice acting.
How I missed you.
Jubei!
Who's there?
Come on!
Nothing bad happens to you when you listen to a voice.
Surely nothing bad's gonna happen to you?
Yeah?
Okay, let's see if there's...
Is there an audio slider?
Sound settings.
Alright.
Sound guy!
What do we do?
It's time!
There it is!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wake up Sam, right?
We got...
Dime...
Dimeyul to burn.
Alright.
Always listen to the voices in your head.
That tells you what to do.
Set...
No, we're not gonna set it tomorrow for the laws.
Bring down BGM by like...
Three.
Okay.
Three ticks.
And bring up overall.
Alright.
Got you.
But how much though?
Okay, I'll bring it up here.
Alright.
Let me know if this is better.
Glad you're playing this game.
Don't get trivia.
I'm sure you know.
But Onimushu gave us...
Oh yeah!
No, I know that.
Yeah.
That's why a lot of the mechanics are very similar.
Okay, I'll save.
That's why you guys can tell that the mechanics are very, very similar.
But I know about that.
Let me run away from the boys.
Wait, is that not away?
Are you okay, bro?
But yeah, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
That's me.
Are you alright?
You need to get out of here.
Right there.
Hey.
Who did this?
Ah!
Jesus.
Whoa!
You think he's okay?
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
You're the ones who attacked here?
Okay.
I did not expect that.
For whom are you working?
Is he...
Is he okay?
Prepare yourself!
Okay.
You're not gonna...
I don't remember how to play this game.
Okay.
No instructions.
Just slash.
Don't worry.
I have no instructions.
I'm just gonna keep slashing.
Whoa!
Okay, I'm gonna go...
Oh!
You're still alive.
Okay, are you dead yet?
Just like old times.
Choo-bay!
Okay, there's...
That's the pokey pokey.
Okay.
Bring down...
Sound effects by two ticks.
Okay.
I got you.
Alright.
Choo-bay!
Alright, and then bring up...
Uh...
Aurora.
Yeah.
The good old classic old games.
You just...
You learn by...
Trial and error.
Okay.
And then this is kick.
Wait, how did I kick?
How did I do that?
How did I...
Look!
Lady!
I'm trying to learn the controls right now!
No!
I need my game manual!
I don't have a game manual!
No!
That's not fair!
There's no game manual on Steam!
Yo, can you know what?
Dark Cloud is probably not a good game, but...
Um...
Awesome at the time.
Lucy, I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
Oh, there it is.
Google a scan.
Let me...
Let me Google...
Hey...
Oneimusha scan real quick, guys.
Okay, I figured it out.
I don't have to just do like...
You know...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I figured out the controls, guys.
That's right.
Slash me.
Oh!
That's right!
Get slashed!
Alright.
You attain...
Oh, nice!
Press the...
Oh!
Thank God!
My first tutorial!
It is to open the map!
Thank God!
That's what I needed.
Where did I come from?
I...
I don't remember.
I don't...
Where did I...
Where did I come from?
Ooh, babe.
Okay.
This way.
Where is this way?
Alright.
I have to go that way.
Where are they coming from?
Okay.
I don't know where they're coming from.
Alright.
I love...
I love fixed camera angles.
Jesus Christ.
Get over here!
Let me slash you!
Nice.
Yeah, I'm glad he waited, too.
Alright, that should be all of them.
You're in the trees!
Stupid!
Oh?
Oh!
That's convenient!
Don't wanna get my feet dirty with water.
I wanna...
Dirty socks...
Wet socks is not it!
Donkey!
Always listen to the... to the nice lady.
If the nice lady tells you to go into the cave, listen to her.
Nothing bad can happen in the cave, right?
Kruger identity.
Okay.
Solid, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's that sound?
I don't like that sound.
Call Dragoon like that, you can damn sure we're accepting the side quest immediately.
Just like Doki telling her to buy her merch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Solid, thank you, thank you.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A voice in my head said to buy Doki merch.
Buy my merch.
I forgot that you always like leave all the controls in the fucking manual.
Adeka, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
A voice in my head.
Into the goon cave I go.
The dragoon cave.
That looks like a nice place to hang out.
Doki!
Oh my god.
Oh, she's a god.
A demon.
Why hot?
I like how she was like a demon?
What the real?
If I called her a demon.
Oh my god.
The suck!
I can suck now.
My favorite.
My favorite power in this game.
Time to suck.
The demons.
Charity?
Faith, honesty, respect, and strength.
Gather all the orbs and defeat Nobunaga.
You must go to the dragon shrine.
See, I told you guys she was friendly.
Then, you may take your quest to build mine in imagination.
When these mysterious women leave me alone in the cave.
They're always friendly.
You can do it.
Just do it.
What?
Sun?
Oh, so how's the volume so far?
Charity orb.
Wait, that's my mom?
Oh my god.
It can finally teach me.
Nice.
Wow, there's my manual, guys.
Okay, just give me all the information, like, right now.
Like, like...
Oh, so am I, like, half demon?
Okay.
Let's tell you good luck.
We're all counting on you.
Oh yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let me just have all the information, like...
All at once, guys.
Like, massive lore dump right here.
Absorb...
Time to suck the info.
Okay.
We'll re...
Press B to suck.
Okay.
Recovers help used to turn into Onimusha.
So they enhance from the magic.
Start infusing your gear with soul.
Each weapon or piece of iron requires a set number of souls to reach Use magic attacks.
Equip an Oni and press Y.
Okay.
Y...
B is suck.
Collect 5, then press L2 to turn into Onimusha.
Okay.
Using a charge attack.
Equip an unhold RT, then press X after a while.
Learning new skills.
Press while holding to cycles through...
Okay.
Quickly turn critic...
Press X right before it to hit and perform a critical.
Using press X while...
Okay.
Press right X before and to perform a...
That seems very...
Let's try this out first.
Let's try...
Let's try this...
This particular move first.
Okay.
Um...
All right.
I got this.
That's something very easily digestible, guys.
That...
That's you.
I definitely...
Look...
Suck.
That's my favorite move in the entire series.
All right.
Let's...
Just baby steps, guys.
We're gonna try and get one thing done at a time.
All right.
And then turn down sound effects by one more tick.
Okay.
All right.
Can't be too hard, right?
Until I fight the boss.
All right.
Where are these?
Okay.
That didn't work.
We're gonna try this.
Okay.
That didn't work also.
Suck.
Don't leave.
Okay.
There we go.
Guys.
Apparently, I'm not gonna do that now.
Oh, shit.
All right.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Don't leave.
Suck.
Oh, nice.
That's a giant one.
That's a giant suck.
Absorb.
Guys, thank you.
Oh, shit.
Where are they coming from?
There you go.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I still...
I definitely...
I don't know how to do the critical attack, guys.
I don't know when that happens.
Oh, wait.
I can suck this.
Jesus.
Where did you all come from?
Okay.
I don't think I can charge it.
Yeah.
This weapon doesn't do charge.
Oh.
I could do this.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Watch me shimmy.
Watch me slide.
Slide to the left.
Slide to the right.
Okay, I'm trying to let... What's the first pre-RT in?
Alright, I'm moving.
Weird demon woman telling you to kill a revived Frutalord that died in this quest to unite Japan.
But you're too tired to go on this quest?
You score Doki Bird to get 10% off on GamerSubs!
To get that energy you need!
Gus, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Alright, I'm gonna go this way.
Okay.
This is the dragon that women mentioned.
It says, prove your identity.
Is it asking me to show the mark on my hand?
Take my hand.
Go ahead and thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What we learned today.
Jubei is our name.
Snake was our dad's game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Did I learn a new comp?
Wait, my sword is so cool!
Oh my god, it's the official sword!
This is my new power.
Does this mean I got the Y attack now?
He sounds like Dante's voice in the first game.
I will get my revenge.
You will pay for this.
Nobunaga!
That's sick.
In 1568, gold was discovered in the valley of Imash, which is situated between Mino province...
Me too.
I love... I love old game voice acting.
And the Echizen province of Asakura.
In no time, adventurers and merchants, motivated by greed, crowded into Imash, transforming the small village into a prospering mining town.
Oh.
Hey, that's good.
See?
Demons aren't so bad.
I love it.
I think my favorite one is...
The first Resident Evil game.
It's like...
My sandwich!
Nooo!
I miss old voice acting.
Why would you show that to everyone?
Oh, I don't think he's okay.
Wait, what happened to him?
A jesus sandwich.
Oh, I love House of the Dead.
You know like...
You know like they still make...
House of the...
They still make like...
Don't you wanna serve me a little sake?
Oh, it's her!
I remember her.
Oh, she has the other...
Thing.
The other orb.
Woman!
I shall protect you.
Okay.
They're still making House of the Dead games.
And the voice acting never improved.
It's actually crazy.
I think they got like staff members to voice act for the game.
To save money.
There was a recent House of the Dead arcade machine.
And it's still the same voice acting.
Like...
Like the same...
Uh...
What's the word?
Campy voice acting.
It's like their thing now.
It's called style.
You don't understand.
Oh, hey.
You look...
Oh, I was gonna say a prostitute and I was like...
Am I allowed to say that?
I was like...
And it was one.
You looking for a good time, sugar?
No.
Well, your expression speaks volumes.
Come back if you change your mind.
I'll be here waiting for you.
Try to come up with something interesting to do later.
Okay.
This town is still kinda new.
I'm sure I could make a ton of cash here.
The man who found the gold in the mine.
I knew he thought he was in heaven.
But it's pretty funny he actually went there.
Well, his loss is my gain.
You're looking for a woman?
Even with a fine specimen like me right in front of you?
Oh my god.
No women in town is more beautiful than I am.
Of that, I am sure.
Jakoto, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't you play Onimusha 2?
The classic Capcom game?
Heck yeah.
The Onimusha series originally started as a feudal samurai Resident Evil.
Like how Devil May Cry started as a Resident Evil game.
So similarities are there.
It's surprising that not a lot of VTubers play Onimusha.
But everybody who keeps playing Devil May Cry.
I drank too much again.
I really need to start taking it easy.
I feel like Onimusha is a fun game.
The rooms upstairs will have free for you to use one if you want.
Can you believe this guy?
He's got no money, but he wants me to sell him my permit.
I'll pay you when I get my salary, please.
I need a permit to enter the gold mine.
For the gold.
Oh, I can enhance.
Alright.
Let's save real quick.
I think Onimusha was a really good game back then too.
Similar?
Oh my god.
I keep trying to save game, but I'm trying to enhance my weapon.
Should I go straight into...
Ooh.
Will I get a better sword later?
Or should I just...
Should I get a better sword later?
Or...
Upgrade my better sword...
My better sword later?
Or should I upgrade it now?
I don't know if I should upgrade it now or not.
Or save up.
That's the thing.
I know I get different weapons, but I don't remember which one...
They all have their own strength.
Okay, I'll upgrade for now.
I'll upgrade it for now.
Just in case.
Ooh, a Kirisu.
Suck.
Wait, is that not for sucking?
Oh, restore magic here.
Okay, I was gonna be like...
What?
A statue of the god of the underworld.
Instead you can see all the deeds from your past lives.
I'm sure I've been a good person in my past life.
Wait.
I was gonna go...
Up here.
Alright.
Oh, I got a floating fan.
Where's my bed?
Oh, I got a cat!
A little cat!
I can't pet the cat.
Nine out of ten.
Never mind.
This remaster sucks.
I can't pet the cat.
Never mind.
No wonder modern games are better.
Can't pet it.
Not.
Why even play?
You're right.
Guys, we're gonna go back to Roblox.
Sailor, if you're gonna go to the gold mine, I heard it's crawling with Oda soldiers.
I'm gonna go up here first.
What's up here?
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Excuse me?
How is there people here now?
Oh my god.
Excuse me?
Excuse me!
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Suck.
Okay, I did not expect to see people here already.
I just wanted to...
Why are there demons here?
Suck.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Guys, give me a sec.
Okay.
Let me...
Oh nice.
Give me a sec.
Let me suck.
Suck.
Oh.
I gotta make sure.
Jesus!
How many people die in feudal Japan?
Trick question.
I don't need to ask.
Oh, I got gold though.
Yes.
Are you serious?
There's so many.
At least there's a fast way to kill them.
Thank god.
I'm glad there's like...
You can just do that.
Yay!
Money!
Am I going the wrong way?
Eh, whatever.
Hello!
Do you have a permit?
Oh, this is the gold.
Did you not just see the demons back there?
Bro!
What the fu- I just fought so many demons!
Oh my god!
And I gotta do this again.
Bro!
There's demons here!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'll fight here.
Oh nice!
I can actually use my electricity attack.
That's good.
What the fu- Where did he come from?
At least I can farm like...
Uh...
Level up.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
What?
That's fine.
I'm trying to remember how to do the charge attack.
Correctly.
Like that?
Can I do it?
Oh, I guess that's the charge.
Alright.
Nice.
That's good.
That's like infinite resp- Uh...
Infinite XP fire.
Yeah.
These guys are good for...
Barming.
Boom.
Good.
Slash!
Okay.
Chill.
Your turn soon.
Yeah.
And I can grab gold too.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Slash.
That's right.
Slash!
I found it.
I figured it out.
Infinite gold.
I don't need to go to the gold mines.
I can just stay here.
Why go to the gold mines when I can just stay here?
Okay, let me...
I think I can level up some stuff, right?
Slash.
Oh, wait.
I've never been here.
Where's here?
Hello, good sir.
I don't believe we met.
This is a general store.
We sell all kinds of goods and trinkets here.
Please, take your time and see if we have anything that catches your fancy.
Yes, you're looking for a special egg?
Oh, this is just food.
A plank- plant encyclopedia?
Oh my god, wait.
I want a parrot.
What?
Yeah.
What do I do with it?
Oh, I took his bird.
I took his fucking bird.
Shut up, idiot.
Do you know who you're talking to?
Hello, doggie.
I came all the way here.
But someone else bought what I was looking for.
The bird?
This woman told me she liked slim guys not too long ago.
My, what a handsome young man.
I like myself a big tough guy.
And I'm sure you like the attention, no?
If you become fit as this guy, I'll be all over you.
Can't pet the dog.
8.5 out of 10.
Alright.
What do I do with a parrot?
What do I do with him?
I'll go back.
I wanna see, like, if there's anything back here.
Is there anything back here?
This famous salt, which Kenshin Usugi gave to his arch enemy, Takeda.
Gotta line up everything nice and proper.
This is your first visit here, handsome.
Oh my god, the ladies wanna flirt with me.
Oh my god.
I'm sure you like this place.
I can sense an air of trouble around on the tourist trap.
I went on a spending spirit star and I got this as a free gift.
You can have it because it's not really my cup of tea.
Oh, it's ancient documents.
What do I do with it?
Oh my god, it is gifts.
Oh, wait, can I...
Can I charm people?
Hey, where's...
Where is it?
Oh, it's a gift.
Wait.
Am I in a dating sim?
That's my friend.
He was involved in a cave-in at the gold mine.
Sonic Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, wait, I can...
Wait, I can have...
I can have a...
Girlfriend?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, guys.
There's hope.
There's hope for us all.
Or...
Oh my god.
Better than that.
A...
B...
Boyfriend?
Oh my god.
A bro-b-b-bro?
Pull the handle?
Yeah.
Why not both?
We can have both girlfriend and boyfriend.
Together.
Oh my god.
More options.
We can have options.
Wait, what did us do?
Where is that...
How do I get to...
Oh, I need a person over there, don't I?
I need a second person.
Enthusiast, welcome to the...
Tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh, is this where I...
Oh wait, no.
Okay.
The fixed camera angles always fucks with me.
There's no game does that anymore.
Alright.
That cloth.
Wonder which one wants this cloth.
It's been so long since I played a game with fixed camera angles.
Alright, we gotta run.
I still don't know how to do the critical attack, guys.
Oh nice, what's this?
I got bow.
How do I use it?
Is that it?
Okay, it seems really weak though, so I don't know.
Wait, the original had tank controls?
Every...
Uh...
Bro, every...
Every old game that had tank controls back then.
Almost every old game had tank controls.
Just... It's a bit random, but you'll know when you pull it off.
Okay, I'm gonna try again.
Okay.
I'm gonna save my...
Oh wait, what?
Whoa!
Oh!
Fantastic job, Toki!
How dare you to serve our time!
Together!
Oh!
That woman gave me the help sign, so I had to break things up between the two of you.
Get over it.
Why is he like...
Western?
Why does he have a...
Seriously?
Cowboy accent?
Who'd want a red bald head like you?
We're in Japan!
We're in...
Yippee-ki-yi-yay!
That does it!
Outside now!
He he he he he...
Like they say in Fudo Japan...
Yippee-ki-yay!
It's a Kansai accent, clearly...
What's he gonna do?
Deflect a bullet?
Did it?
Born in Texas, Japan.
Such trifle things.
And you are...
Jubei Yeggyu, the young chief of the Yeggyu.
Oh, that's me!
Jubei!
Hey, Jubei Yeggyu, who is master of the blade!
It must be faith that three proud warriors meet in such a town.
Austin Osaka!
Is that it?
Is that easy?
I did it!
I've... I've...
Guys, discovered world peace!
Oh, nice!
Give an item and you can expect something helpful in return.
A mark will appear on the lure when you approach a character.
Repressed to open your very choice gift.
Didn't give.
Do you want my parrot?
Of course I'm gonna pick the guy with the gun.
Like, what the fuck?
Like...
Here.
You want my parrot?
Why are you doing a parrot?
Why would you need a parrot?
Okay.
It looks like he is completely...
Oh!
I received medicine!
Look!
He's a neat guy!
Alright, wait.
There's something I wanted to...
Uh...
I wanna look at my instructions again.
I don't know how to do the parry.
This one.
Right before an enemy hits it?
That shit looks so hot.
Alright.
Um...
He's...
He needed it.
I don't know.
I guess he needed...
Self-esteem boost?
You think he'll like...
You think he'll like this?
Yeah!
He likes it!
His face does not...
Oh.
Okay.
Well...
Fuck you, I guess.
I gave you free stuff and you're not even reacting?
I think he'll...
I used in...
Okay.
What else would he like?
Would he like cloth?
I suppose it could come in handy.
Yeah?
You can use it to wipe...
He frowns?
Am I...
Like...
He...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha...
What is this hot cold?
What...
I got that...
What is this hot cold shit he's doing to me?
What if I give it back to him?
Oh shit, I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
You quietly take back the cameo.
Why don't I give this to him?
Do you want this gift?
Oh, he did not like that.
We just met!
What?
He starts to mope like a little baby?
Do people not like free stuff anymore?
Give it back.
Give it back to me.
I know there's like a healing thing somewhere.
Where's the healing shit?
Get it.
Gifts are... Get a guide on gifts!
Okay, alright.
What do you think he likes, guys?
Alright, we don't need him.
Gifting is a serious... Alright, Doki.
Don't fuck around!
Wait, I still don't have a permit.
What the fuck do I do?
What?
Maybe play hard and get seal off Magachi's bullet.
Dorma, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, this is the real game.
I'm trying to min-max my gifting right now.
You think he likes to smoke?
I want to brag, but I'm super into reading books and studying.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh, so you're into books.
Oh, oh!
Okay, I got you.
Oh!
I've been looking for this book.
Thanks.
I'm doing it.
I'm gift-maxing.
I'm romance-maxing.
Oh, a power draw!
Okay.
Then that means you want this one.
I got it from the other guy.
It would be better to read them all at once.
What's this here?
He frowns?
Oh, I got wine though.
Oh, I know who likes wine!
You like to drink!
Italian drink?
Holy shit!
Okay, you better like this.
I love good drinks!
Yeah, this guy, this is from straight up Italy!
Ooh, I got some more medicine.
Alright, so you guys, I know how to min-max this shit.
What do I do now?
Ah, save after that.
Enhance.
Alright.
I keep swapping.
Alright, I'm learning, guys.
I guess I'll head back and see if I can go back to the cave.
Is there somebody at the second floor?
Alright, I'll go check.
I didn't check the second floor.
Oh my god.
Okay, there you go.
I got a little lost there.
Yeah, there's nothing in the second floor.
There's my cat.
That's the remaster.
Talk to the MPs.
Oh, this guy?
Oh, wait, he's new!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, yeah.
I have the permit.
I didn't realize he like disappeared.
Alright, now I can go to the caves.
Alright, here I go.
Sorry, I was playing the main game.
Okay, back to the side quest.
Hahaha!
Alright, back to the side quest of this game, guys.
Let me make sure I stab him real quick.
I assume the red ones do more damage.
Okay.
Let's suck all this up, just in case.
Boom.
Okay, I don't know... at the moment, if...
If... if I'm... if I'm in this animation.
You know the one where I'm like putting the knife in?
If they can interrupt it.
I can't tell yet, because none of them have yet to try to interrupt it.
Back to the minigame.
The children yearns for the mind.
Alright, get out of here.
Nice.
There's so much gold.
It's a nice farm place.
Hello.
There's my permit.
You can go in.
Yay!
Alright.
Let's open this.
More books!
More gift maxing.
Monsters!
In the mines act!
Monsters?
A woman wearing armor went in there.
I... I... I tried to stop her, but...
What?
You mean the monsters that are in the pathway of the...
The same monsters that are guarding this pathway?
Oh, they're running down.
No.
That's not good for them.
Oh, wait.
The guard's gone.
Wait.
I...
I bought a permit for no reason.
I bought...
What the fuck?
I could've just waited.
What was the point?
Yeah, I just...
I needed to wait two more seconds!
Okay, uh...
Let's see if I can enhance this.
Oh, not a lot though.
Which way?
Left or right?
Go left side.
Left seems less dangerous, right?
Whoa!
I knew it.
Nice.
Whatever there are demons, you will find mysterious doors.
The doors are protected by strange demonic creatures called mozun.
A pupil of gill strings created the mozun from bright moss under the ground.
There are several types of mozun and their sole reason of existence is to protect the demon's secrets from intruders.
Humans are not allowed in.
However, they are weak against the only power and to be destroyed with the right type of weapon.
Oh, that's a story I have.
Oh, fuck.
Um...
My favorite.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I figured it out.
I love these puzzles, guys.
I love these...
I love...
These are my favorite puzzles.
I got the secret.
There must be something in here, right?
Fly to the right.
Fly to the left.
Oh, oh wait, hello.
I wanna see what the hub about this mine was about.
This place is a dump.
Where is the entertainment?
What is he like?
Oh, I don't really have anything, actually.
Yay, good.
Oh, nice.
We needed that map.
Okay, so this one's a dead end.
And I assume the top is where I have to go.
Criss-cross now.
Alright.
I don't like it.
There has to...
I feel like something's gonna pop up and go ooga booga booga.
Oh, there it is.
Fuck is that?
Oh!
Crocodiles.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
There's no way I...
I knew it.
I was like, I feel too safe.
That makes no sense.
What the fuck?
Get outta here.
Get outta here!
Suck.
That's right.
Leave!
It's this way.
Are they Kappas?
Uh, they don't look like Kappas.
Oh my god, they're blue, too.
Suck.
I was gonna say, how the fuck do you live that?
There's no way.
I don't think they're Kappas.
Wait, let me see.
Oh, you thought you got me, huh?
That's fucking right.
I'll waste my magic on you.
Okay, I'll go down here.
I think there's loot down here.
Yeah, they look like...
They just look like...
Just like regular...
Alligators.
That's right.
So apparently this has infinity frames.
Oh, they waited!
They're so nice!
That's so nice of them!
Nice!
Thank you for waiting.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, nice.
I need the energy, too.
Oh!
Please form alive!
See, this is why I min-maxed my gifting to the gun guy.
Like the lizard people.
I gave you wine!
I gave you Italian wine!
That's fucked up!
You suck this while he does all the work.
I'm ready!
You do the thing!
I do this!
He asked if I was ready!
I just started blasting!
Please help us!
My daughter...
My daughter was kidnapped by monsters!
Wait!
Did you say daughter?
Ugh!
Sooo...
Emotional support too big!
Oh, of course!
I think she is the most beautiful girl in the world!
Of course he's interested now!
He's like...
W-w-woman?
Assuming this is the Tokugawa era, he ain't getting any more of that wine.
Because the...
Shogune almost completely shut off trade.
Wait!
So that was black market shit!
Velarius!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you there!
I know!
And then he didn't help me!
Wait!
What's on top then?
If that was like part of the story...
What was that?
If that's part of the story...
I'm gonna go back.
And then see...
Where the top part is for...
I'm curious then.
Mukulichi, you fool!
I won't forgive you!
Wait...
What?
What's going on?
You're like children.
Where...
They're here now?
Not yet.
Where am I?
I have to settle this first.
Dream of becoming a feudal lord.
I'd do anything to make it happen.
Anything!
Did I go the wrong way?
That isn't walking the right way?
Yes!
The...
The point is...
Makuichi laughed on my dream!
I laugh because it's silly.
Jubei, what's your dream?
I don't have a dream.
Ha!
Jesus!
I will kill Nobunaga!
Jesus, that's depressing!
I've never been possessed by a vengeful ghost.
A vengeful ghost?
What do you mean?
Makuichi!
I keep pressing the wrong button.
No, what?
Which way is the right...
What?
I keep pressing the other...
How?
Jesus, I am so confused.
I'm gonna go back.
I think the other way was actually the...
The bonus way.
Alright.
Okay.
Wait.
Suck.
Nice.
Let me suck first.
Jesus.
Jesus, they're so...
Oh, fuck!
He came behind me!
It's like I didn't expect it at all!
Wait a minute.
Gotta get rid of...
Oh my god!
They just keep coming!
There's so many of them!
Okay.
I'm just min-maxing right now.
I also wanna make sure I have enough magic for the other...
For the boss fights.
What are you doing?
What are you doing coming back to me, huh?
You know what's gonna happen to you?
What's over there?
Oh, it was nothing.
Oh, okay.
I should've just...
So the other way was the right way.
This was nothing.
What's this weapon?
Ooh!
It's a spear!
Five Oni Orbs.
I am descendant of the Onichi Hogan Clan.
Famous as a yin-yang master and a formidable strategist in Kyoto during the Heian Period.
The Onichi Hogan Clan, as the name implies, are descendants of the Oni.
It's said that the founder of the Onichi Hogan Clan was entrusted with the five orbs of the Oni Clan.
The five Oni Orbs are secret orbs that grant great power to those brave enough to stand up against the demon.
The five orbs are charity, faith, honesty, respect, and strength.
He who took over the Onichi Hogan Clan had been looking for the five Oni Orbs for generations.
I finally found the charity orb in this gold mine.
However, the demons are all around me and will not be able to make it back alive.
Therefore, I have hidden the cherry orb, and I have left this memo for a brave warrior to find.
Oh, so there's a... there's one of the orbs are in here.
Also, I for... I know I asked earlier about...
Um...
About, like, the sound.
But I don't know what the sound guy said.
I missed out on what the sound guy said.
If it was okay, or if I need to...
Or if I need to fix anything.
Whoops.
Alright.
Oh my god, the spear is so much better.
Wait.
The spear is really good against these guys.
Holy shit.
Wait, this is so much easier.
Alright, nice.
What did my sound guy said?
Is it okay?
Or should I...
Adjust it anymore?
Uh, Jonathan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just gonna run past these guys.
For nearly two decades?
I do not remember the name of this game.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I can kill them.
Oh, fuck.
Get out of here.
That's right.
I can thrust forever.
Power up the thrust.
Boom.
That's right.
Thrust.
Oh shit.
There's so many of them.
Okay, we need this.
I'm just farming HP at this point.
Did I kill all of them?
That's right.
Can't get up.
Oh my god, that was a double kill.
Just that easy.
You're still coming over?
Have you not learned your lesson, old man?
That's right.
I don't remember the name of this game.
I thought it was just a dream.
My brother and cousin shared.
My quest is now over.
Thank you.
There we go.
That's right.
I'll never stop.
Yeah, loot.
I need to use medicine.
Okay, save.
Save complete.
Enhance.
Oh wait.
I wanna upgrade this.
Wait.
What's this call for?
Wait, guys.
Oh wait, never mind.
I had a random call and I was like, what the fuck is that?
Oh, put the charity orb?
Yes.
I was like, who's calling me?
Text.
Oh.
Steam?
Steam power?
My Fudo Japan right now?
What the fuck you are doing?
How do I remain my Territor?
That's me.
We are looking for a woman.
Guys, do you know where his...
Where do you think his weak point is?
His exposed eye?
That's where his...
That's on his crouch?
Or like...
I don't know.
The giant exposed eye?
Or his ponytail.
You're right.
Or you think it's his ponytail, guys.
Surely not, right?
Can I block this?
Oh, I can.
That's good.
Jesus.
Actually...
I just was curious about...
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
Okay, there you go.
That's right, it's time!
That's right!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Pew, pew, pew!
I think that's the...
Okay, that's good.
I can block that.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
What the fuck!
Did you miss me?
Shoot him!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright, we just need a little bit.
That's fine.
All right, I believe.
I'll do one hit, and then he can keep shooting him.
Does he die?
Jesus Christ!
Oh, he's sucking me!
Does he die?
There's no way, right?
I think he'll be fine.
He'll be fine, right?
He'll be so healthy.
I knew it.
I knew he was gonna do that.
He was so... I... Oh!
How do you do that?
Dude, just keep moving.
Just keep moving, Doki.
Just keep moving.
Just... Suck.
Just that easy.
Just...
Suck.
Just keep thrusting.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I suck.
Oh!
Get me out of here!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna use the sword.
Fuck this.
Fuck this!
Okay, the sword was definitely way more effective.
I should've been using the sword this entire time.
I wasted so much mint.
Goodbye.
Okay, bye.
Thanks for the help.
Alright.
This is one of my favorite games.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you to the super chat, Nito.
Thank you.
Brandon, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, Pokebird.
Okay, I think the spear is good for, like, lots of enemies.
But the sword might be good for, like, boss fights.
Maybe.
Wait, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Hey.
What's wrong?
You seem like you're dying.
Huh?
Wait, but you guys all seem so happy.
You guys were like, good, yippee.
Here,
drink some water.
Where did I get this...
meal?
Oh, I took him home.
Okay, I was like...
Did I just bring this to the mines with me?
I feel fine now.
By the way...
The woman you were looking for...
Might have been taken into the hole.
It's like, here's my bento box I packed.
Yes, it's inside the gold mine, but the opening is blocked.
There is one way you can enter the hole.
It's the hole.
Where the gold is.
What the fuck?
Why didn't you give me that earlier?
What's that?
I don't know exactly.
But you can open the cover if you place this on top somehow.
I just found it lying around there and I kept it.
Like the ancient donut.
Please, take it.
Inside of the gold mine.
Yes.
I have to go now.
Thank you.
For everything.
No problem.
You're giving me the ancient donut a little earlier, but that's alright.
That's alright.
Fuck me, I guess.
Gotta go back into the mines.
Alright, I got the red ring.
Uh...
I like this during...
When I'm attacking the minions.
I think the sword might be good for the...
For the, uh...
The boss fights itself.
Because that was such a waste of meds.
Door dash to the mines.
That would be 500,000 yen, please.
Door, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, I got more books for you.
Wait, does he only like alcohol?
Sweet...
Oh, something sweet and alcohol.
Okay.
I have more books for you, though.
It would be better to read them all at once.
Yay!
A wind bell.
Let's save our game.
Always keep saving.
I should be able to enhance, too.
Enhance the sword, then.
I have to sort for, like, boss fights.
Oh, yeah.
Give me a sec.
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
I have to adjust the sound.
He said, sound effects down a tier.
There you go.
Oh, yeah.
Give me a sec.
I have to check my email real quick.
I got a voicemail.
Oh, all right.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll do that.
Okay.
It's basically, I need a refill on the prescription.
So, let me check this real quick.
Oh and here..
Oh, my gosh.
Oh,
okay.
I can pick up any time tonight.
Alright, let me... I got to pick it up tonight.
Sorry, I just got the email, but yes, I can pick it up tonight.
If possible.
I just got the email and voicemail.
But yes, I can pick up tonight if possible.
All right, nice.
When did they send this?
What time did they send this email to me?
Oh, shit.
Wait, what?
What time did I reply?
Oh, okay.
I did not see that.
All right.
It was in the morning.
They called me today about it.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
I got it.
Whoops.
All right.
I'll go pick it up tonight after the stream.
Yeah.
Well, his meds are, like... He has, like, four more days of his meds.
So, like, I just want to pick it up in advance before, you know?
Before he runs out instead of picking it up on the day he runs out.
All right.
Back to gaming.
No, we're not going to do it now.
The hospital... It's a 24-hour hospital.
So, I can pick it up whenever.
And he's cured.
Oh, that's so silly.
Cured forever.
We're hopes and dreams.
You still live in such a hopeful world.
A dual monster.
What the fuck?
Oh, new monsters.
Oh, these guys.
I remember these guys.
I hate it.
These are, like, OG Devil May Cry enemies.
They remind me of, like...
Oh, there it is!
I did it!
I don't even know how I did it!
They cry enemies.
Yeah, I remember them.
Yeah, yeah.
It's in the first game.
Whoops.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Haha, whoops.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, I got...
I did critical attack there.
Yeah!
More money to spend on gifts.
Yeah.
The puppets.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was...
Oh, my God.
Are you hungry?
Are you hungry, little guy?
Oh, my God!
I'm so sad.
No one's trying to feed him!
I can't check this monster fill mine.
If I had any unusual, let me know.
Wait, what the fuck?
They're just going to mine as if there wasn't monsters here?
What happened to the daughter?
No, you're right.
What happened to the daughter that I'm supposed to save?
Feed him the daughter.
Oh, there they are.
Oh, my God!
It's just a giant eye.
Okay, nice.
I'm going to suck this real quick before...
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
That's fine.
I got double attack.
Wait, there's one more?
Okay, nice.
Stab!
Oh, nice.
And it gives me the Oni Musha.
Brandon, they give us super...
Wait, what?
What are these guys?
Wait, these guys are new.
Oh, shit.
These guys are...
Oh, my God!
They're strong!
That's it.
I'm bringing the big boys.
Oh, my God.
I got the...
I got...
Okay, I got to get this real fast.
Yeah, these...
Like, the big guys...
I definitely need the sword for that.
Oh, thank God.
It gives me HP.
Yeah, I definitely need the sword for the big boys.
What the...
Oh, it's these guys!
I remember them.
Oh, my God.
That was instant.
Wait, I did a critical on that.
I don't even know how.
I wish I had lock-on attack here.
Nice.
Okay.
Get in here.
Yeah, I didn't even realize I did double crit there.
That was crazy.
That was a crazy double crit.
Jesus, guys.
Chill!
Oh, my God.
Fucking chill.
You fuckers!
Give me the heals!
Oh, I don't even have full HP for that.
Yeah, it was definitely very hard to do.
I don't even know.
I definitely got lucky for that one.
Yeah, I should be able to enhance now.
Come on.
Yes!
No!
I was so close!
Oh!
Wait, wait, no.
Did I level up?
Oh, no, I did!
Nice.
Okay, and then I'll try and do...
I didn't hear no bell.
What the fuck?
Wait, how did he get here?
Yeah, I'm just going to use magic.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
No, actually.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
No, don't suck.
Don't get me.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
What the fuck did he do?
No, not again!
Not again!
Thank you.
What the fuck?
I'm trying to get out!
It just keeps sucking.
I swear to god it was not intentional.
I swear to god.
It just keeps sucking.
Wait, there we go.
We did it.
Despite all odds.
We fucking did it, guys.
The suck of doom.
Despite all odds.
Okay, and then... Where's my fucking donut?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, I can use this now.
What the fuck?
Why didn't I give it to me automatic size?
Welcome to the...
Is that how you felt when you watched me get sucked three times in a row?
Welcome to the tomato file.
Welcome, welcome.
He's like, this is my time to remember.
This is it.
Oh, this is like where like there's multiple boss fights in a row.
I remember this.
Oh, I remember this.
Multiple like fights.
Yeah!
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait.
Whoa, we're starting now?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I missed.
Oh, my god.
Okay, it's okay.
I'm okay.
I swear to god.
Alright.
That not it?
Oh, there was more?
Oh, shit.
I need to know his patterns or some shit.
Okay.
Nice.
Suck.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Go steal your souls and try to want to take care of them.
Oh, they do?
Okay.
That's good to know, Brandon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't know that.
There's a seal that I can't open it.
Just break it open.
Just pour water on it.
Alright.
Up I go.
Okay, nice.
Don't worry.
I know your pattern.
That's right.
Oh.
I know your pattern.
Suck.
Alright.
I have demon form for this fight.
So it should be alright.
Oh.
Where am I?
What is this world?
Doors locked.
Oh, I know this place.
I know this place.
Guys.
My dad got lost here.
He got confused.
Which one?
Oh.
You must have new wife and kids.
It's the same for you.
If you should defeat Nobunaga.
Another will rise to take his place.
No, he'll just keep coming back to life.
It never ends.
Yeah, but then I'd be dead when it happens.
That's all that matters.
I'd be dead though.
So it doesn't matter to me.
Okay, nice.
We actually need that.
It's about like, you know.
Am I gonna be alive for it?
If I'm not gonna be alive for it, it's okay.
Jesus Christ.
Let me get that suck off first.
Please!
That's it.
I'm bringing the sword out.
I'm mad.
Oh fuck, JK.
Look, when I say that, it means I do better.
Oh my god.
Someone kill this bowman.
I can't kill him because I have to deal with him.
Okay.
If I'm down here, he can't do anything.
Oh my god.
That's it.
Give me a sec.
I'm bringing up my own bow.
He gets me?
He's so...
He's so hit!
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh my god.
We actually needed that.
Wait, what's this?
What does this mean?
9...
14...
15...
7...
8...
9...
10...
11...
12...
13...
Oh!
15!
So he just has to make 15.
Okay.
3...
8...
9...
10...
11...
12...
No.
3...
6...
7...
8...
9...
10...
11...
12...
13...
What?
This is 2, right?
8...
9...
10...
11...
12...
13...
Oh!
Okay.
We'll put 8 right here.
4 here.
And then...
Wait, no.
That doesn't make sense.
That's...
Oh, wait, no.
And then 2 here.
And then 6 here.
Yay!
I used my fingers to count.
I did it.
Does my spear also have...
Oh, yeah, it does.
Okay.
Nice.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
I'm leaving this area.
No!
Don't bring me back!
Oh, thank God.
No, just suck him!
Suck him!
Just suck him!
Oh, thank God.
Okay, don't worry.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no!
That's fine!
As long as it's not me!
As long...
Thank God!
That's fine!
I got saved!
Okay, I'll go right side.
Right side seems to have, like, loot.
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
It's technically a G-Fu castle now.
It belongs to the...
Alright.
Is that anything that he likes?
No.
I think this is all for the...
For the lady.
Look, when he got him, I knew that I'm safe.
Like this?
Then...
No.
That's not it.
Fuck!
Okay.
Oh, I fucked it up.
No.
Oh, how do I get this to the other side?
No, what do I do with this?
No!
Um...
This?
Oh, I'm so stupid.
I'm...
Yay!
I figured it out!
Yippee!
Yeah, I'll get that.
Yeah, you only have three moves.
I keep seeing that button is where I'm supposed to click.
Okay, there should be a heal here.
Never mind.
Oh, it's like...
This area again.
I remember this area.
No!
No, I need a sock!
Bro!
Oh my god, you fucked him up.
That was my XP.
That was my XP, bro.
Oh my god, you fucker.
You fucker.
That was my XP!
Here you go.
Nice.
Wait, you guys told me that doesn't...
You liars!
You guys told me I get involved!
Liars!
I'm not invincible?!
I'll...
I'll upgrade this.
Imagine trusting...
I thought I was invincible!
One tells the truth, the other tells the lie!
Fucking...
God damn it!
Okay.
Put that on.
Dragoo is lying!
They will never!
Okay.
Brandon, thank you!
Super chat, thank you!
Thank you!
Oh nice!
More books for my friend maxing.
What?
Are you okay?
Yeah?
Oh Jesus Christ!
That's fine.
You can do that while I do this stuff.
Oh wait.
No!
I'm just gonna do that.
Oh shit!
Wait, that's so good!
They locked him!
Nice lock.
Okay, nice.
What's this?
Wait, it's a baby!
Whose fucking baby is that?
Also, Syze!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I just got free from working.
I was working with family and helped produce the game show panel!
Hope you enjoyed that!
You're very legitimate non-Google victory!
Yeah!
Wait, that's the daughter?!
Thank you very much!
He took a baby to the mines?!
What?!
You said daughter?!
You didn't mean baby daughter, did you?!
Why they took a baby to the mines?!
They yearn... sorry for...
Oh, you're right!
They yearn for the mines!
They get them young!
Start them young!
Take your baby to work day!
Aw, he's getting PTSD from his dead baby!
What the fuck?!
My daughter!
What?
When the castle fell...
My daughter was crying like this!
I did everything I could to rescue her!
Bro...
Uh-oh...
He has to take his men!
Aw...
Eke...
When she was born...
I promised her...
When she grew up...
I would become a feudal lord...
And make her a princess...
Aw...
That's why he wants to become a feudal lord!
Okay...
Alright...
You have your baby back while I went through traumatic PTSD!
Don't put her near any fires!
Like I just stood there while his daughter was just like...
Yoinked from his hands!
Who's gonna protect that guy from the demon infested castle?
Are we just...
Not...
Hello?
Did we not just fight like hundreds of demons?
Like...
Is no one gonna...
Haha...
No one gonna...
Escort him out of this demon infested area?
Like...
He...
Don't worry Toki...
He can handle it!
Haha...
Out of sight...
Out of mind...
Like...
You know...
I thought...
One of us would...
Escort him...
I guess...
But I'm asking too much!
Haha...
Oh nice...
Oh I must have...
I might have messed up some...
Shiny eye objects...
Maybe...
Actually...
Shiny eye use the spear?
Maybe the spear?
Maybe the spear...
Is that opening?
Oh my god!
What the fuck!
Where did you come from?
Hello sir!
Alright...
Match the color?
What color?
Am I not...
Do I not have anything for this?
Actually I don't know...
I don't have any other weapon though...
Not yet?
Oh...
Where do I go?
There's an area right here...
Okay...
I guess I need to find a different weapon...
Yeah...
I was gonna sit like...
Oh this fucker...
This fucker...
Get out of here...
Get out of here!
Yeah...
I don't think I have a weapon for it yet...
Oh wait...
Alright...
Don't worry...
I trust him...
Are you ready?
Ready?
Free loot!
Yeah...
I'm ready!
Free suck!
Let's go!
Come on!
I'm ready!
Where are you?
Wait...
Is he dead?
No...
He's still shooting him...
Ready to get loot!
Yeah...
Alright...
I'm done...
I'm done looting...
Jesus...
Okay...
There's a lot of people there...
I wanna...
God damn it!
Stop dodging!
That's cheating!
Okay...
Nice...
Get more level up...
Jesus...
Is there more of you?
Fuck!
Okay...
It's fine...
Just getting more level ups...
Nice!
Wait...
What's this?
Oh...
Fire arrows!
Alright...
We have to go like...
Outside...
I feel like...
Yeah...
Is that here or to the left?
I'm just gonna run past all of these...
Enhance...
I'll level up my spear first...
Before I level up anything else...
Save...
That's right...
Not even gonna let you TP yourself out of here...
That's right!
Think I'm gonna let you slowly TP up?
Ha ha ha ha ha...
That's right!
Ha ha ha ha...
I'm stupid!
I'm gonna let you just TP up...
Slowly...
Ha ha ha ha...
Yeah!
That's right!
Get out of here!
Ha ha ha...
If you don't...
Uh...
You can only load back to your save...
So I have to save...
Fuck it...
You got this...
Ha ha ha ha...
It's this area...
Wait, how do I...
How do I get to there?
I go from the side?
It might be the side...
Okay...
Here?
What?
Okay, where is that area?
Did I see that?
Wait, where did my gun guy go?
Oh shit...
I'm trying to figure it out...
Where to go...
Like here!
There's something...
That side...
I assume...
Alright...
Oh no...
I can run past all these guys, right?
No!
Wait...
Shit...
Okay...
Wait, where do I go?
I'm lost...
I'm actually a little lost...
They're not...
Okay, so there is...
Near far...
Unexplored...
There's a door in the small hallway?
Which one?
Okay...
Because we can't go through this door...
Goodbye guys...
And then...
There's nothing over here...
This is the only issue with fixed cameras...
It's so hard...
It's so hard to figure out where things are...
Okay...
Here...
Is there an extra door I did...
Oh...
Here...
I didn't see this door...
Ghost...
You can see me, can't you?
You must have a grudge against Nobunaga...
As I do...
I was sent to Gifu Castle as a scout...
And was caught and killed here...
And now...
I've been caught by the evil energy...
Haunting this well...
I'd like to give you something...
But I can't even do that now...
However...
If you can obtain the purified charm from the castle...
Then maybe we can help each other...
Okay...
Where the fuck is that?
The birth of the demon clan...
Began many years ago...
It's said that the king of the demons...
Was born in the chaos of the universe...
And that he created Earth in 13 days...
Before spawning the demon clan underground...
Then...
Ford and Brahe has planted the seeds of life...
And all across the globe...
And created the animals known as...
Humans...
As the perfect food for demons...
Humans refer...
To demons as devils or monsters...
Yet very few are aware of what demons truly are...
The demons and humans came to an agreement...
Where the demons provided science and technology to humans...
And in return...
The humans provided many sacrifices to the demons...
Because however...
Wait, what?
That's not a bad deal...
There's too many...
I mean...
People are already dying anyway...
What?
Like...
Science and technology?
I mean...
We could go to space!
There's however...
A clan of Oni in a country called...
Zipengu in the far east...
Which had lived there since before the humans were born...
This clan...
If you feel so bad...
The demons...
Oh, it took one guy...
It literally took one guy to fuck it all up for us...
Like...
I'm sorry...
Just feed them the elderly!
It's just...
Like...
They're...
Or like the sick!
They're about to die anyway...
We get science and...
Look, I'm...
We get science and technology!
We literally...
It took one guy to fuck this up...
Fuck this really good...
That was a good deal, chat!
That was a really good deal!
In your...
In your annihilation of the Oni clan...
It said their few only...
Their only weapons will still remain...
Hidden in the dragons...
As in Bak...
Zipengu...
But no one knows where exactly...
Look, not me!
I'm very healthy!
Not me though!
I don't understand!
I'm missing a weapon!
Wait guys, where do I go?
I'm a little lost here...
For this one...
Like, I'm missing like...
A weapon...
Apparently...
Oh, did I actually have a purify charm?
Oh!
I forgot this game...
Like...
It doesn't automatically give it to you...
If you have it...
You have to like...
Actually...
Hand it over to him...
I forgot about that...
That was my bad...
Yeah...
I did find one...
Thank you...
Now I'm free from the evil energy...
And I can rest in peace...
Goodbye!
Now go...
And defeat...
Nobunaga!
Yay!
He's free now!
What did I get from that?
Oh!
Nice!
Alright...
Before we do...
I'm gonna use the bathroom...
I've been hydrating a lot...
I'll be right back guys!
I'm back!
I had a little snack too...
I get myself a little snack...
You guys like spending time with a dead corpse?
You have fun?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha...
With a...
With a dead body...
While that was gone?
Alright...
Ha ha ha...
Nope...
Uh...
Morbid Boss Pyre!
Hey guys!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hey Toki!
I hope you're having the best stream!
I have some birthday obligation to go now...
So I hope you and chat have a great weekend ahead!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
I hope you have a good time at the birthday party...
It's this way...
Okay...
Let me save my game real quick...
Alright...
Give me a sec...
Two bros...
The moment I put this on...
I'll fight you!
Thank you for waiting!
The door's been unlocked...
JK!
Ha ha ha ha ha...
I wasn't gonna fight you...
Cause I'm a pussy!
Oh, it's this guy...
I hated that guy...
I hate that guy...
Sorry...
You're very clever to stay here with me...
Instead of returning to his side...
Which is falling!
Uuugh!
I hate that guy!
Oh my god...
He's a creep!
Uuuh...
Uig...
Bro...
Uuh..
So serious...
You're feisty...
As always...
Anyway...
This is the will of our lord, so I cannot allow you to leave this castle.
Or help out.
Yeah, it's me.
Wait, what?
He attacked the village just to kill me.
Damn, we're not much of a threat if we stood in your way.
Like, I don't understand...
That wasn't much of a threat then.
If it took that fast to kill us off.
Wait, no, come back!
Wait, no!
Wait!
Two hands is better than...
What?
Wait!
Why?
Why did I tell her to leave?
I...
I don't understand!
Why did I tell her to leave?
Two hands is better than one!
Excuse me?
Where did she go?
She just left...
She just left like that?
That's fucked.
Oh, that's a new sword!
Oh, that's not my new sword!
Never mind!
Ha ha ha ha!
Or stay!
Who are you?
Oh, I'm glad you asked!
My name is...
Who are you?
Jurgen Dantus!
The greatest swordsman of all demons!
This hair is like a mushroom!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Bro, you can't say that, Jube!
You can't say that!
He's just a little...
Like some buoyant, man!
My sword is trembling with tears of excitement!
Why you got nipples on his armor?
Why does Superman wear his underwear outside his superhero suit?
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
Does he deflect everything?
But...
Wait!
He does!
Wait, how do I kill him if he just deflects everything?
Oh my god!
What do I
do?!
Use what?!
Come on!
Oh my god!
Goodbye!
It is...
Yeah, it was scripted.
I was like, what the fuck?!
That was an entire...
You are too weak to take me on.
Oh my god!
He called me weak!
Let me at him!
Hold me back, though!
Hold me back!
Hunter, thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Time for a rocket launcher!
You know, if...
You know, if that one clan didn't fuck it up for all of us, maybe we would have a rocket launcher by then!
What's that?
Oh!
We gotta put the...
The...
Oh!
Gotta put the...
Jewel in there.
Okay.
The faith orb.
Yeah.
Oh!
What's in it?
What do I see with my special eyes?
What the fuck?!
What year is this?
What?
That's a...
That's a mechanical horse.
Are real horses just not good enough for me?
Like, it's not even a magic horse.
It's a robot horse.
I...
I don't remember this.
Not even a fucking magical horse.
It's literally a robot horse.
Get on.
I don't remember this at all.
Get on this weird metal horse, son.
I can't pet cats, but I can pet my magical...
My...
Sorry.
My robot horse.
Oh, she's...
Oh, she's so shy.
I...
She's like...
Yeah?
Me and the samurai on...
What?
Where is he gonna go?
He's a fucking robot.
Like, just park him next to my fucking inn.
Where is he gonna go?
He doesn't even need to eat.
He's just...
I never did.
Get your name.
What?
He's eating robot horse.
Don't we gonna think this weird?
I have a fucking robot horse in the horse stable?
We had no chance against his army.
So I went to Gifu castle to kill Nobunaga myself.
I was caught.
I understand.
You won't steal...
You won't download a horse, would ya?
I'll be here in Amashu for a while.
Whoa!
Oh, this is fast.
Yes, we would.
Anyway...
Thank you for helping me.
If you need anything...
Please...
Let me know.
Yeah, I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Horse-shaped Audrey goes into the horse-shaped hole.
I think the other horse is like, Bro, what the fuck?
I used to get...
Bro, this is so funny.
He's just like, Bro, what the fuck is that next to me?
He's just standing there.
He's not even moving.
There's no animation.
Because it's like, you know, fucking meta.
Hey, that's me.
Huh?
Who are you?
Kotaro Fuma.
A young chief of the ninja group that the Hojo clan retains.
What do you want?
Oh my gosh.
I'm like an encyclopedia.
Let me give you some advice.
Watch out for that woman Oyu.
She's hiding something.
I can feel it.
I'll find out what it is.
Bro, what?
We just met.
He's like, don't trust women.
I'm like, bro, are you okay?
Who hurt you?
Like, the inst...
Like, he's just instantly like, don't trust her.
Alright, I'll go back.
Wait, is he okay?
Wait, is...
Is he okay?
You think I'm drunk?
Wait, I have more books for you.
Don't worry.
I got another book.
It would be better to read them all at once.
Yeah!
Normal bullet.
I don't have a gun yet.
Oh!
He likes me now!
Wait, what?
Oh!
Wait.
What?
Two women?
Wait, what?
Did you send...
Did you buy me a...
Did you like...
Buy me time with women?
Where's the second woman?
Who are these people in my...
Wait.
Oh!
Okay, there's her.
Where's the other one?
Where's the...
There's a second woman?
Oh wait, I should buy...
You should write.
I should buy more gifts.
You're right.
Oh!
I get a special discount!
What do I want to buy?
Oh, vodka.
Okay, let's buy vodka.
Since we have extra anyway.
And then...
Oh!
Yes!
Let's get a love potion.
And then...
Oh, we should...
A novel depicting indecent relationship between...
It does not leave but...
Yes!
Let's get that.
Let's get...
Oh my god!
I'm ready.
Wait.
Does it work on...
Does it work on the guys or only...
Or only the women?
Where's the...
Is it her?
Look at me!
I picked wrong.
Guys, I picked wrong.
Guys.
I...
Oh.
Oh, it's not.
I don't know.
I got too greedy.
I got too greedy, guys.
I...
You and that hateful woman, Takajo, must die.
Oh!
Guys, I got too greedy.
She said two different women.
I was like, oh, I want to know what this new woman looks like.
I got played.
Wait, what?
No.
No!
I was about to go!
I can't even go back!
I just...
No!
It's too late.
Oh, no.
No!
I got too greedy!
Now I have no women!
I don't know.
I...
I'm so sad!
I can't believe it!
When they said you can only pick one!
I thought he was joking!
I was like, teehee!
I was greedy!
I was so greedy!
This is the greed they talk about in the Bible!
This is it!
They talk about me!
No, it's too late.
I already saved.
I live with my consequences and my choices.
You gotta live with your choices!
You gotta...
You gotta know your actions have consequences!
Don't be greedy!
Don't be greedy like me!
You should've went with like...
I should've went with the one that I knew...
The one that I knew...
She was so good to me and then I...
I squandered it!
Wait, how do I get to this chest?
There's no save points in life, guys!
You gotta live with the choices you make!
And I made a really bad choice!
I...
I ha...
I like how...
Oh, rats!
I like how, um...
One of the gifts is like, nearly just a fucking fork.
Like, what the fuck?
It's just a fork.
Oh, nice!
I don't know, I just thought it was kind of blue.
A special fork.
Hahaha!
There's like a door right here.
Like...
Here?
Alright...
Wait, where is it?
There's like a door somewhere here.
You guys see it, right?
Oh, here.
There it is.
Okay, there we go.
I should open it if I insert something here.
What do I insert there, though?
Charity?
No?
I don't have any other orbs.
Okay, yeah.
No, I don't know if I could do that.
Hahaha!
I don't know!
What?
Who's shooting me?
Oh, all the way here.
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god.
The map!
You won this time!
Okay, oh, I got the other one!
I got the other one, but where...
Where's that supposed to be?
Is that a gift?
No.
Oh.
My naughty navel.
Hahaha!
Sorry.
There it is.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Like, sometimes I just can't shield fast.
Ah!
I hate that you can't...
You can't fucking- Ah!
Ow!
Okay, I got it.
I'm okay.
Sometimes I just can't block fast enough.
And it's like...
A little tilting.
When you can't do it in time.
Jesus.
No!
Not what I wanted!
Stop!
I wanna kill him!
I don't wanna kill you!
No!
Alright.
I kept auto-targeting these two over there.
Yeah, but...
There's like...
An area right...
There.
That ghost...
Oh!
That's the secret area that I need to find.
Oh, there's this chest.
Oh, nice.
T.
Alright.
I should have everything, right?
Yeah, that should be everything.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't have a thing for this, so...
I gotta find it.
Yeah, now imagine if I had 10 controls.
This is technically easier than before.
Cause back then it was a lot harder to play these games.
There we go.
Alright, I go home now.
Oh, nice.
That's what I needed, actually.
I still can't believe it.
I was so greedy.
Alright.
There must be like lock on in this game, right?
Am I just missing it?
There must be a way to lock on.
Is it R1?
Is it?
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
If it what is...
No, it's not.
R1 is the map.
Is this turn?
Is it RB?
No, because like...
It can't be because...
Um...
It's not RB.
Is it?
No.
That's just turn.
Are you so...
Oh, you fucker!
Nice.
Alright.
L1?
No.
Yeah, I don't think it has...
I don't think there is lock on.
I hate you.
I fucking...
Jesus Christ.
This stupid arrow.
Oh my god.
He's still there.
Okay.
That's it.
I've had enough.
You've arrowed your last...
Your last mass.
I'm like...
That's it.
I've had enough.
Oh, you too?
Oh my god.
That's it.
Don't piss me off.
Oh my god.
That is friendly fire.
No.
Nobody likes...
Is this how...
Is this how they felt when I was playing...
Is this it?
Is this how they felt?
Is that why I had to take all that stab?
Is that it?
Was that how they felt when I was the archer and night ring?
Whoops.
I went backwards.
Now I understand.
Get out of here.
I swear if you fucking come over here.
I swear to god.
Get over here.
Stop dancing.
No dancing for you.
Dancing is out loud.
It should be here.
Wait.
She can just do that?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
You're a demon.
Just regenerate.
Mom?
I wanted much more time to talk with you.
Joe.
I mean, you could have visited me whenever.
But like, that's cool.
I was like, I was like literally right next to your...
I was literally like, right next to you.
My village was next to you.
What happened?
I chose wrong.
The first time I met.
She revealed that she was my mother.
I chose wrong.
I chose my father.
One day, I met your father.
And fell in love with him at first sight.
Oh, that's my dad.
Wait, did she have the snake body too?
When they met?
Bro, he's a freak.
He saw...
Bro, she saw the...
The snake body and was like, yes.
Finally.
Hahaha.
It...
It was destiny.
What?
Hear me out.
Hahaha.
This woman told me that.
It is the Yagyu clan's mission.
To stop the demons.
When they rise up to the surface.
For this, the chief of the Yagyu clan...
He was like...
I thought...
I was just not into anything.
Until I saw...
Hahaha.
The snake torso.
Earth.
And the demons of the underground...
Fought a great war.
In the end...
The demons won.
And the Oni...
Were scattered.
I never knew my mother.
So a woman appeared...
All of a sudden...
And claimed to be my mother.
And stated...
That I have the blood of the Oni clan.
I...
Can't just accept it immediately.
I'm at.
You have demons.
Huh?
Oh?
Sucker up.
Sucker soul.
That's XP right there.
No!
You're wasting XP!
Jubei!
But if it's true...
If this is my destiny...
I'll accept it.
The XP!
I'll be this Oni warrior.
And I will destroy the demons!
Yay!
Oh, that XP is just floating away!
What a waste!
That could have been on my sword!
Oh my god!
Oh, there's the ring!
Wait, my house is dead, God.
What the fuck?
But my girlfriend just left!
My soon-to-be girlfriend!
Don't worry, guys!
My...
My soon...
Okay, not that!
My soon-to-be girlfriend!
Lali, thank you, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Okay, please understand, she couldn't visit him because she was busy studying marine biology!
Guys, does this only work on her or does it work on any of the...
Any of my...
Friends?
I'm just curious.
Oh, new monster!
Oh, what?
Oh.
Oh, I have to get...
Try and hit...
I have to hit it when...
That makes sense.
Okay.
Never know till we try it out!
This is important, guys!
I spent $3,000 on these rings!
Nice.
Oh my god, please!
Look into my eyes!
Open your eyes!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh shit, I didn't see him.
Nice, okay.
Got him.
Get over here.
I need that extra XP.
I couldn't suck up my...
My mom's XP, so I need it off of you guys.
Yeah!
Okay, now that I have the ring, I can go back.
Swear to god.
Oh my god.
I swear...
I swear!
I just wanna kill you.
I don't care.
I don't care about anyone else here.
It's just you.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, I got ricochet there.
Oh my god.
Oh nice.
Friendly fire.
Thank god for that.
Oh my god.
I have to do the extra suck before I get near.
Oh my god!
You fucker.
Get over here!
Okay, nice.
Enhance.
Short time.
Should I be enhancing my armor?
Do I get better...
Oh my god.
I...
I have not been giving a fuck about my armor.
I just realized I had...
Do we get better armor later?
Or is this the only armor we have?
I don't...
I don't remember.
Okay, I think it was...
Here?
And then here?
And then this way.
Okay, I remember.
Okay, and then we gotta put the ring.
My dead mom's ring.
Yay!
Oh.
Yes, I need to turn the place and complete the picture.
What?
Oh no.
I can't read this.
Guys.
Guys, I can't read.
I...
I can't read.
Guys.
What do they read?
Which one's white?
I don't remember.
Is this Norse...
What?
Okay, I must have had a book about this.
Do I have a...
Oh, there we go.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, black, blue, red, white.
Okay.
Okay, I found a...
Okay, black, blue, red, white.
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
Black...
Blue...
Red...
What?
There we go.
Yay!
Down the ladder I'll go.
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
There's nothing here that...
I need to worry about.
Other than that.
Honestly, I...
Didn't think that would work.
Oh.
That might have been a mistake.
I just, you know, figured the first time it did...
It went okay.
So then...
The second time it would be okay.
Wait, is it still...
Heading over?
Is it like...
Like...
What is it doing?
Is it still...
There?
Oh, it is.
There.
You...
Oh, f...
Oh, shit.
Okay, I got...
I got...
Confused.
Okay, there.
Okay.
I got...
I got really confused.
I don't know.
For some reason, I thought it would just disappear.
I...
It was just...
I thought...
I don't know.
I just thought it would just disappear for some reason.
I don't know why I thought that.
Oh, wait.
It's a different color now.
It's purple.
Oh my god, stop.
I'm having...
Oh my god, please.
I will use magic.
I'm done.
I don't care anymore.
Go over here.
Alright.
Get over here.
That's right.
Oh my god.
He wants to join in the fun, too.
He's like, let me at him.
Let me at him.
Let me at him!
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Come on.
Just drop down, buddy.
Just drop down.
You can be part of the fun, too.
Just...
Alright.
Just let me slowly climb up.
And then you can join in.
There you go.
Are you happy now?
Did you have fun?
There we go.
Did you...
Did you have fun, sir?
Yeah.
Was that fun?
Was that...
Did you have fun over there?
It was so...
You look like a fucking puppy.
He's like...
Oh my god!
It's my dude!
Alright.
Using some kind of trick, I can't open it?
What the fuck is the trick?
Oh, let's do this.
This is green, right?
Is this not green?
Or is that blue?
That's blue?
It's still not opening.
Give me a sec.
Buddy!
Oh, I need green sword?
Oh!
Okay.
I was gonna say...
What the fuck?
Do I just not know colors anymore?
Like...
Am I...
There's no way I just suddenly became colorblind.
Like...
That's not...
That can't be it.
That's like...
That just suddenly...
Like...
When you get older, you just become colorblind?
What the fuck is going on?
I'm gonna fuck this.
I don't like these guys, too.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I gotta make sure I got these guys out of the way.
Okay.
Oh my god!
You can do that?!
I'm just gonna block for now, just in case.
There's...
Jesus, what?!
There's no pattern for that!
He just...
Chucks it!
Brandon, thank you the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got the herb.
I got another map.
Oh.
Oh, thank god!
I got the...
Green sword.
Nice!
Oh, it's a double sword!
Whoa!
That's cool!
Alright, let's try this one out.
Sen...
Senpumaru.
Let's save.
Nice.
Oh my god, it counts my save.
Don't look at it.
I...
I just realized...
It counts my save.
Don't judge me!
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I wanna go back, cause now that I have this, I can unlock the area.
Oh, fucking Christ.
Oh my god, that's it.
Shoot him.
Oh, you're not gonna shoot him?
Okay, I see how it...
I see how it is.
Nice.
That's fine.
I'll take those.
Okay.
I'll get him...
Rid of him first.
Jesus Christ.
It's gonna take you a while to fucking get that arrow in.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I need a...
There we go.
I see it.
Down I go.
Okay.
Oh nice, I broke it.
Yay!
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
Like, what do I get out of that?
Oh, this...
This one's weak.
I don't know if I like it.
I'll just use it for the magic.
I'm not really a huge fan, because he seems really...
It seems like such a weak one.
Yeah, it's like fast hit, but pretty weak.
What the fuck?
I stabbed you!
Oh my god, it doesn't even do final hit for it too.
Yeah, I don't know if I like it.
I think I can do it twice.
Okay, this one...
Final hit it.
Yeah, I even like stabbed him in the belly and he still lives.
Yeah, the fatal blow...
Is it a level?
Could be.
Yeah, if it's...
I'm gonna...
I'll wait until I level it up first.
Jesus.
What the fuck?
Why is there another guy?
Oh my god, he's slowly heading over to me.
Jesus!
Oh my god.
I'm getting doubled.
Oh.
There we go.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I can suck this before I go in.
Oh, it's fine.
What?
Oh my god.
I'm being really cocky right now.
Nice hole.
Come on.
Heels, heals, heals, heals.
Okay, just a little bit.
That's okay.
No, I gotta save the magic!
Okay, that's fine.
Being a little too cocky right now.
Enhance.
I don't even think I have enough to enhance.
Oh, this is gonna take a while to enhance too.
Get outta here.
Oh, nice heals.
That's good.
I'm glad I got the heals last minute too.
Cause I was definitely not okay.
Oh, that was a big heal suck too.
That's right.
You're so weak.
You're just father to me.
That's right.
Nobody loves you.
Not even your demon daddy.
That's right.
Get stabbed.
You're just XP for me.
What's easing?
Guys.
What's that?
Let me read my book.
Enhancement.
What's that?
Is that the charge attack?
What the fuck is...
What do you want me to use?
Oh, wait.
What is that?
Wait.
Am I not...
You not hit it?
You not hit that?
What the fuck?
What is that?
What?
He just...
He left.
How do I...
What?
He just blew away.
What does that do?
And this guy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't know what the fuck that was.
I tried to figure it out.
I didn't mean to use magic.
God damn it.
I'm sad.
I didn't mean to use magic there.
Alright.
Sucked.
Oh, he's still alive?
Nice.
I got fire.
We actually need that.
Okay.
Oh.
That's magic too.
We actually need that too.
Get over here.
Suck.
Nice.
More fire arrows.
I'm so lost.
Like...
What?
This?
Are you supposed to tell me where to go?
Where do I go?
Oh.
Wait, I killed him.
Oh, I just...
Oh, I was just supposed to stab him.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
I did it.
Yay.
Murder.
See?
Murder is sometimes okay.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Oh, yeah.
If you don't know what you do, just start swinging.
If you don't know what you're doing, just start swinging.
Eventually, something good will happen, right?
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I don't know how I'm gonna get to him.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh my...
I'm...
Oh, I got him.
I got him.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I got him.
That was...
That was just so difficult.
That was so frustrating.
Cause it's like...
What the fuck?
It just shred me like that.
What the...
That's it.
I'm...
I'm done.
That's it.
You fucked around too much.
Jesus.
Okay.
That's good.
I'm worried I'm gonna accidentally go backwards and then have to redo this again.
Okay.
That's nice that I know that I can stagger.
Are you serious?
Get outta here!
That's fucking right!
Now give me my HP back.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Now they're...
Oh my god!
No.
No!
Thanks.
I just started...
Oh and I lost everything.
I...
Thanks.
I just started swinging.
My XP gone.
No suck.
Is that her?
Oh my god.
It's her.
Her.
Lady, I chose wrong.
Bro, she like killed my mom who's like...
A bit...
Like a stronger demon.
I don't know what I can do.
You gotta live with your choices, guys.
You gotta live with your choices.
Haha.
What?
Whoa.
Chill.
There's enough Jubei for...
There's enough Jubei for everyone.
I told you I'd be back.
I'm immortal.
Wait, does that make my mom still alive?
What?
No.
No, he's just dead dead.
Wait a second, gingham fats.
This cute little man is mine to play with.
No.
I claim his life.
Alright, you go first.
I know you'll lose again anyway.
Whoa.
Damn.
How dare you.
Alright, I know...
Don't worry, I got this.
I have...
I might not have gun man with me to...
Whoops.
Okay, now...
Now I got this.
Now, now, now, now I got this.
Now I got this, guys.
Now, now, now...
Guys, now...
Now I know what I'm doing.
Okay, that was awkward, but...
I now know what I'm...
I definitely know what I'm doing this time.
I know it seemed like I didn't before.
Okay.
Wait, I can't absorb this.
Okay, and then...
Okay, I can swap...
Wait, it's like...
Okay, I wanna know how to swap my weapon...
Oh my, I'll just do this.
I don't remember the...
The thing to swap the weapon.
Easily.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's good.
And then...
Again!
Wait, where is he?
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Bro!
Are you serius?
What am I...
I'm so sad.
I'm...
I...
I'm so...
Yeah.
I'm so... I can't...
Are you fucking...
Okay.
He he he he.
He he he he he.
He he he.
Oh shit, fuck!
Oh fuck!
He actually!
He'd me!
He'd!
He actually!
He actually did it!
Okay.
I figure it out.
He actually that madman.
You actually hee heed me correctly.
I wasn't paying attention.
Was that noticeable?
Oh shit.
I was trying to cr- I... It's so hard to time.
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
Jesus.
Okay.
No, not that, not that.
Oh, whoah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Oh, whoah, woah!
He's a lot faster now!
Whoa!
Whoa, guys.
He's a-he's really fast now!
Okay.
No.
Not again!
And...
Okay.
He has like... two hits here.
No!
No, no, no!
Okay, I have to heal.
Oh my god, I have to heal.
Oh, thank god!
There we go!
No!
Oh, I'm saying!
You would have died a lot sooner?
When...
If I...
If I didn't fuck up my second ult!
My stupid second ult!
Oh my god!
He's like...
He he he!
He...
Which way do I go?
Is it this way?
Okay.
Stupid.
He he he.
Oh my god.
Wait, what the?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, there's like babies, too.
Jesus Christ, there's so many.
Oh my god, I can't believe...
They're so tanky!
This is it.
I'm angry.
Oh my god, it takes that much to kill a child?
Jesus!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I got the crit for that.
Jesus, they're so tanky.
They're so fucking tanky.
Oh my god, how many children do you have?
Get out of here!
Your parents are dead!
I've killed your parents!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god, there's more?!
What?!
Is that an egg?
Oh, this is where they live.
Whoops.
Sorry.
Hmm.
I may or may not be the bad guy.
Hahaha!
Hey!
Ooh!
Whoa!
Oops!
That was...
They live here!
Hahaha!
Whoopsie!
Yeah!
Awkward!
Whoa!
There's a slight chance I just killed...
I just...
I just made...
Did a home invasion.
Maybe.
Haha!
Just a maybe, guys.
Oh...
Whoa!
This might be where I get crushed.
Oh, I have...
Two of them.
Wait, where's the other ones?
Did I miss one?
Oh...
Guys!
I did not pay attention!
Hahaha!
Did you pay attention?
Did you...
At Croc!
Which way?
Because I definitely did not.
At Croc!
Guys!
Oh!
Oh, thank God.
Nothing bad happens.
Okay.
Oh, I can't pull the lever again.
That's...
Oh...
Guys!
I can't pull it again.
Wait, I missed one.
Where did the last one...
Oh my God.
I missed one?
Oh no, there's another area I didn't go.
Okay, thank God.
Oh hey, look!
A new...
New family!
Look at that!
See, guys?
I'm not that bad of a person.
A new family moved in!
Look at that!
What the...
I'm not that bad of a person!
New family moved in, guys!
WTF.
What?
What is going on?!
Jesus Christ, I'm leaving.
You guys can live there!
I'm leaving!
Yeah, I should have level 3 and level 2 now.
Alright.
Oh, whoops.
Okay, no, that's not where I wanted to go.
I wanted to go this way.
Yeah, there's another area here.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Whoa, fuck.
He choked me.
It looked so fancy.
Okay, like, I didn't expect it.
He, like, it looked so... he was, like, doing some cool moves.
So then I was like, whoa, look at him go.
You know?
Like, look at him go.
Yes.
Jesus.
I wish I could time the crit better.
But I'm so bad at timing it.
Alright.
That should be... that should be the statue.
The last one.
Yeah, it was.
Alright, most likely I might get crushed.
Most likely.
I don't know.
I have a bad feeling about it.
Okay.
Where's this area?
I don't know how to open that.
Oh, there's more children.
They all live here?
Alright, let's leave.
I don't want to deal with these kids.
Fuck.
Okay, I need to go back.
Alright.
What the fuck you?
Alright, we save here.
And then...
Alright, let's leave.
I don't want to deal...
I'm not a home invader.
Alright, I most likely fucked this up already.
I most likely...
Fucked it up already.
Because I was definitely not paying attention.
Let's go gambling!
Oh...
It was so close!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Sword...
Cross.
Sword cross.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I know, I know now.
Sword...
I memorized it.
Oh, thank God.
Sword.
Alright.
Sword, cross.
Okay, now, thank god.
Thank god, this game decided to be like, oh, it's okay.
You get one.
Everyone gets one.
There you go.
Yeah!
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I gotta worry, not gonna lie.
There is a save near us.
I fucking knew it.
I heard those stupid boos.
Wait.
Where?
Oh, that's fucked up.
I run past it.
I'm not dealing with that.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Wait, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Okay.
Those are some ladies.
You know what?
I'm just gonna use this.
I'm just gonna use this real quick.
Those were some ladies.
That's what they were.
Oh my god.
Oh, he just slammed into me.
You know what?
That's fair.
Oh my god.
I actually might die.
Let me grab...
Actually, no.
I believe in me.
Yeah.
Look at that.
I was so confident.
For no reason.
Holy shit.
Ladies.
Hey, nice.
In the diary.
Oh my dearest Lord Nobunaga.
You're so beautiful today.
With your pretty hair and gorgeous body.
Lord Nobunaga.
Oh my Lord Nobunaga.
How cute you are.
The moment I gaze you upon your well-toned and sensual body.
Lie lifelessly before Jesus Christ.
I knew that you had captured more than just my heart.
I winly and lovely devote.
Damn.
Get yourself someone who is still in love with your dead body.
Okay, no.
Actually, no.
That's fucked up.
No, that's...
No, guys.
That's necrophilia.
Do not...
No, that's bad.
I know that you can sense my feelings.
My telepathy.
And yet, you do not even glance at me?
Why?
What?
How shy you must be.
But that just makes me love you more.
Maybe you think that I'm too.
And beautiful and dazzling for you.
Feeling like mine can often be a curse, I suppose.
That's bad, guys.
That is actually bad.
Alright, I guess I'm fighting her now?
I'm
fighting with you for a very long time.
Are you ready for me?
Yes.
Give it up.
No man would ever want to play with a nasty thing like you.
Oh.
I don't think you should make her mad.
She seems to be very strong.
She...
Oh!
Bro, she like sat on me.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
What the...
Okay, now I know.
Bro, I can't even get closer.
Bro, what?!
She's... She's spamming!
Oh my god.
Bro, am I playing Street Fighter?!
Bro, wait for it to get close.
Fuck this.
I... What do I do?!
I'm getting zoned!
I'm actually getting zoned right now!
Zoned so hard!
Is this a new truck?
I'm trying to fight... I swear to god, I am trying my best to fight back.
Bro, she's literally like...
She's like... Pepper!
Pepper!
Salted Pepper!
Oh my god.
Now she doesn't zone!
Okay, bitch!
Like... Oh my god!
It's... It's the sword.
She only zones me when I'm on the sword, apparently.
Nope!
JK!
Shit!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's such a bitch!
He's such a bitch!
She's actually such a bitch!
How do I... I...
I...
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
I... I'm gonna... I'm gonna freak out.
What the fuck?
What... Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, we gotta get meds.
I'll use the medicine.
Wait, can I actually break the... Oh my god, I can't.
Oh my god, she does so much fucking damage.
It's actually... I don't know if it's worth it though.
No, it's not.
She's so strong.
I don't have a lot of medicine left.
What the fuck?
Okay, it's just like that.
Oh my god.
Please, please let me have this at least.
Oh my...
Okay.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
I just have to do that.
And then... Okay.
Okay.
All right.
I got... I got the pattern.
Oh, I don't.
JK.
JK, I don't have the pattern.
All right.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's bad.
I only have one more heal.
This is my last heal, guys.
Oh, no.
If I miss one shot, it's like...
Oh!
Oh, no.
It's... beautiful.
The beautiful man himself.
I use so much... Guys, I'm fucked right now.
Later on.
When I don't have meds.
I'm... I'm... Oh, this is gonna be bad.
We did it.
But at one cost, thank all my meds.
All my fucking meds!
At least I got the other gem.
I got the honest yore.
Nice.
Yes.
Alright.
Yeah, I definitely need a level up armor now.
Yes.
Yeah, I wish I could take their umbrella.
Just trying to make sure there's nothing I'm missing.
Herb time!
Oh!
Wait, what?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I thought I was gonna... Oh, thank God.
I thought... I was like, after all that, this would be how I'd die.
I was gonna say, I... I would be so sad if that's how I was gonna die.
After everything I've been through.
Where the fuck am I now?
Oh!
Okay, secret medicine.
I need that.
Somewhere in the ocean lies a solitary island wrapped in dense fog known as Onigashima, the hidden fortress of the Oni clan.
One day, the demons, fearing that the relationship between the Oni clan and the Yagyu clan would become too strong, attacked the Oni clan and finally located Onigashima.
A young demon swordsman and three evil soldiers ventured into Onigashima and wiped out the entire Oni clan.
After that, the demons remodeled Onigashima and put it to their own use.
As it's surrounded by violent waves and storms, no one can reach the island by ship.
However, there was a vehicle that the Oni clan would ride to cross the seed.
Before the Oni were defeated, a prophet predicted that, a hundred years from now, a hero of Oni origin will come to Onigashima to reclaim it.
That's me!
I'm in the prophecy!
That is unfamous.
That's me.
I'm so famous.
Wait, this is a short game.
I almost have two more orbs.
Alright.
There's a round hole with the word honesty on it.
Oh my god.
Now I have a fucking jet ski?
Like...
Look at my jet ski.
All I'm saying.
Fuck the Oni clan.
We could have had this.
Wee!
We have a submarine jet ski.
Wait, are you saying I could have had armor?
Do I get to go back to her?
Do you know who he reminds me of?
The...
The Aquaman guy in Rick and Morty.
Your eyes betray you.
Your eyes reveal that you are thrilled to encounter a man who is stronger than you.
Whatever.
Mr. Nimbus, yeah.
He looks just like Mr. Nimbus.
So,
let's get started.
What?
Bro!
He breaks through guard?
Oh my...
This better be scripted.
Bro, this better be scripted.
Like, what the fuck do you want me to do?
Oh my god.
Just...
This better be scripted.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
If this is not scripted...
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
That's...
That's fine.
That's That's more than fine.
That's more than fine.
Alright, that's more hidden.
That's more hidden.
Fine.
Alright.
I forgot about the armor again.
I... Wait, how do you get the armor?
Wait, how do you get the armor though?
Wait, how do you get the armor?
Cause I can't... I don't think I can upgrade the armor in time.
Oh!
Oh, I thought you meant like, there's an armor I can find.
There's no way.
I don't think I can... Oh my god.
I don't think I can like, find... Like, the issue is that I don't think I can like, uh...
I don't... I don't have enough to upgrade it.
I'm pretty sure.
Jesus Christ!
I can't even use magic!
Oh my god.
I'm trying...
Oh.
Bro, he's just... He's just styling.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know.
He's just so fancy.
Like, he's just...
He's just dancing around my body.
Like, at this point.
Look at him go.
He's... He's so fancy.
He's like, that's cute buddy.
That's so cute.
That's...
You're right.
Let me just shoot my bow and arrow.
Look at him go.
What?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yeah, I...
I don't know, guys.
Oh, I did it!
Scripted loss!
Let's go!
My scripted loss.
Great.
How shameful to be saved by her twice.
Well...
I guess you can't help it.
So...
Let's postpone...
This game for now.
Oh, he's like playing with me.
He's like...
Goodbye.
But...
Maybe we can begin a new game.
Lord Nobunaga is going to attack Odani Castle.
Huh?
What?
It is only a matter of time before Odani Castle falls.
Oh, thanks for telling me!
What will you do?
You're like...
What the fuck?
This is so campy.
Like...
Why is he...
What kind of boat is that?
He goes in his...
In his mechanical boat.
What the fuck?
There's Mr. Nimbus.
His...
The future motorboat.
He controls the police.
Well, that could've been our mechanical boat.
If the fucking...
Oni...
Oni clan didn't fuck this up for us.
We could've all had these boats.
Oh!
There's my dead mom.
How can this be?
I'd like to express my thanks to you.
For saving my son.
I have a favor.
Marry my son.
I'll just get you my son.
I'll give it to Jube.
And give it to Jube.
Sacred flute?
It is a secret instrument handed down in our own land.
I give you my son.
For the instrument, he's gonna compete with that demon swordsman.
Find the sacred flute.
Loot.
Then, I will find it for Jubei.
I'm glad to hear that.
Thank you.
Oy you.
Goodbye now.
Goodbye.
Alright, I got the red sole bracelet.
Alright, let's save- we're gonna call it here.
We're gonna call it here, sorry.
I'll finish- I don't think I can finish it.
I know I'll- personally, I don't think I can do one shot this.
I- I'm getting tired.
So, we'll finish it next time.
Also, cuz like, I know she's weak as fuck, so I don't really wanna play as her right now.
I- I think I'm- I'm like halfway there, right?
Am I halfway there?
Guys?
I did like a three-hour members- almost a three-hour members stream this morning, too.
So I was like, oh, I should rest up a little.
Uh, yeah?
Okay.
So, yeah.
I can finish it next time.
That was really fun!
I had a really fun playing, um...
Um...
Sorry, my brain like blanked out.
Ha!
Onimusha!
I had a really fun time playing Onimusha!
Um...
But yeah, thank you everybody for coming!
Uh, tomorrow, there is a very special announcement on Twitter at 12pm.
So, yeah!
Look forward to that!
Um...
But I had a great time with you guys today.
Uh, it was really fun going back through memory lane.
Um, and everything.
I got beat up really hard today in Onimusha.
Um...
Ha!
Yeah, but it's been a really fun play through so far.
I'm really looking- I feel like they made it more silly.
I- They definitely made it a lot more silly in 2 compared to 1.
Cause 1 did not have all this magical mechanical shit going around.
Ha!
2 is definitely a lot sillier than 1.
Anyway, guys.
Um...
I'm gonna head off now.
I hope you guys had a fun time hanging out with me today.
Yeah, the robot horse was- Was crazy.
I was- I forgot about the robot horse.
Um...
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
Also, I can't believe I made this game harder for me.
Because I chose Ra.
I- I wanted to be greedy.
I was like, oh, there's her.
But I wanna see who's the other- who's the other lady in the market.
Oh my god.
2 women wanting to talk to me!
And then I lost my chance of getting better armor.
I'm so sad.
Ha!
Anyway guys, I'm gonna head off now.
I'm gonna stay one more time.
Uh...
I'll see you guys later everyone.
Bye guys!
Mmm...
Bye!